that the country works to keep the
overall death toll down as far as
possible while the battle against the
virus has reached a new milestone the US
Army opening its first-ever field
hospital in New York City first in
memory anyway only on CBS this morning
we went inside that new hospital at the
Javits Convention Center with Army Chief
of Staff General James C McConville he
says that what the army learns in New
York could be a model for the whole
nation we will win right when he matters
the virus General James McConville has
seen heroism before as a veteran of the
wars in Iraq and Afghanistan but the
fight against kovat 19 is unlike any
other in his long career it's kind of
interesting when you take a look at the
heroes in this fight I'm gonna be the
doctors the nurses the scientists and
the medical professionals hospital
centers that are here we met up with the
general as he got a final briefing and
tour of the new Javits Medical station
it's designed to handle non kovat 19
patients freeing existing New York
hospitals to expand their fight against
the virus and they're able to manage
patients from routine all the way to the
most severe depending on the equipment
that we have sure McConville says the
PlayBook could we use nationwide
army-corps our engineers are in every
single state they are working with the
state and local officials they've done a
hundred and eighty-one assessments of
pre-existing facilities like this so we
can rapidly stand up hospitals and we're
working with femur and FEMA's the one
who's fighting all these type of quick
may say one hundred and eighty one
assessments yes one hundred and
eighty-one assessments of pre-existing
structures some arenas some hotels and
the intent is to quickly turn them into
some type of healthcare facilities to
give the states options they give them
additional capacity in their states but
with half of its field hospitals now
dedicated to the fight against kovat
nineteen the army could soon face
staffing shortages of its own how do you
staff these hospitals to fight kovat
while maintaining the Army's capability
for the outbreak of war well we do we do
it with very careful management you know
we're managing risk we know what we have
we know we have available would that be
calling up volunteers new recruits what
we have we have called up volunteers but
we have in the Regular Army right now
what we need to protect the nation and
defeat any anyone that wishes us harm
the hospitals are part of a wider US
military effort to beat back the virus
so the Army is providing medical support
logistics planning a vaccine research
right if things become severe can you
foresee a future where the Army is
enforcing a possible quarantine I I
don't think so I mean I think what I see
is the Army is here to protect the
nation
not the police summation we don't have
that type of order we have not been
asked to plan for those type things and
so I would not I wouldn't say that so
this is a place that's literally going
to save lives starting today this
hospital can help save about a thousand
lives at a time right next week you have
three thousand [ __ ] yes sir it's pretty
incredible McConville says the army is
here for the long haul
the Army's vision or mission is any
adversary anywhere anytime that's right
I guess you do mean any that's right
we're here to protect the nation and
right now as the president said this our
nation is threatened by this invisible
enemy this virus and we will defeat it
it's hard not to believe them there
there are nearly 600 active-duty medical
personnel and support staff at that
medical station they are working with
more than 350 medics and nurses now
consider this the army is officially a
resource of last resort it's used only
after city county state and civilian
federal resources have been exhausted so
this is truly a major milestone and
anthony and many of the medical
personnel there have dealt with combat
injuries but they say it's no different
treating civilian injuries medicine is
medicine and they're some of the best in
the world at it
yeah and we're really glad that they're
there for us right now we need them
certainly here in this city